As the entertainment world reels from the
death of Matthew Perry, some of his "Friends"
co-stars have taken to social media to share
their touching tributes.
From guest stars like Morgan Fairchild to
the main cast, here's what they had to say.
On "Friends," Maggie Wheeler played Chandler's
on-again-off-again girlfriend, Janice.
Off-camera, Wheeler and Perry were pals, and
she was among the first to pay tribute to
him on social media.
She wrote on Instagram:
"What a loss.
The world will miss you Mathew Perry.
The joy you brought to so many in your too
short lifetime will live on.
I feel so very blessed by every creative moment
we shared."
Morgan Fairchild, who played Chandler's complicated
mother Nora throughout the run of "Friends,"
acknowledged Matthew Perry's death on X, formerly
known as Twitter, writing,
"I'm heartbroken about the untimely death
of my 'son', Matthew Perry.
The loss of such a brilliant young actor is
a shock."
Fairchild went on to offer her thoughts specifically
to John Bennett Perry, his father.
The elder Perry worked together with Fairchild
on the 1980s soap operas "Flamingo Road" and "Falcon Crest."
John Bennett Perry also appeared on "Friends"
as Mr. Burgin in a Season 4 episode.
It also seems as if the two shared a close
father-son relationship, as Matthew posted
a picture of them together on Instagram recently.
Selma Blair paid tribute to Matthew Perry
on her Instagram, where she affectionately
referred to her one-time "Friends" co-star
as her "oldest boy friend." Blair wrote,
"All of us loved Matthew, and I did especially.
Every day.
I loved him unconditionally.
And he me.
And I'm broken.
Broke hearted.
Sweet dreams, Matty.
Sweet dreams."
Blair played Chandler's flirtatious co-worker
Wendy in the episode "The One With Christmas in Tulsa."
It was a memorable role that unfortunately
didn't recur throughout the series.
Another famous Chandler ex-girlfriend on "Friends"
was Kathy, played by Paget Brewster, who hung
out with the group during Season 4.
Originally introduced as a new girlfriend
for Joey, Chandler finds himself falling in
love with her despite all his efforts, eventually
culminating in a scene where she gives him
a haircut and they kiss.
"Did you sleep with her?"
"No, no, no, I just kissed her."
"What?!
That's even worse."
This incident nearly destroys the iconic bromance
between the two roommates, which is only resolved
after Joey makes Chandler sit in a wooden
box and think about what he's done.
Following this, with Joey's blessing, Kathy
and Chandler briefly date.
However, their relationship doesn't work out
in the end.
Brewster also shared her response to the tragic
loss of Matthew Perry.
In a post to her X account, she shared warm
memories of the actor, writing,
"I'm so very sad to hear about @MatthewPerry.
He was lovely to me on Friends and every time
I saw him in the decades after.
Please read his book.
It was his legacy to help.
He won't rest in peace though..
He's already too busy making everyone laugh
up there."
Two days after news of Matthew Perry's death
came to light, the remaining cast members
of "Friends" came together to honor their
friend and co-star.
They wrote in their statement to People,
"We are all so utterly devastated by the loss
of Matthew.
We were more than just cast mates.
We are a family."
They added that they are taking time to process
the loss of Perry, and they will have more
to say in the near future.
The actors concluded by writing,
"For now, our thoughts and our love are with
Matty's family, his friends, and everyone
who loved him around the world."
Their statement came one day after "Friends"
creators Marta Kauffman and David Crane, as
well as executive producer Kevin Bright, released
a joint statement of their own.
Their statement said:
"We will always cherish the joy, the light,
the blinding intelligence he brought to every
moment — not just to his work, but in life
as well."
They also recalled that from the very beginning,
they felt Perry was the absolute perfect fit
for the role of Chandler Bing.
To say they were right would be an understatement.